[Applaus]
[Musik]
meine liebe zuschauer in diesem video
wollen wir donald trumps amtszeit als 45
der präsident der usa von 2016 bis 2020
einer nüchternen objektiven und vor
allem tiefgreifenden analyse unterziehen
dies ist bitter nötig da viele trump nur
nach äußerst ober rechtlichen kriterien
beurteilen was seinem habitus stil sein
auftreten mehr nach seinen worten als zu
seinen taten diesen fehler wollen wir
nicht beginnen
sehen wir uns also an was trump in den
letzten vier jahren ist substanziell
bewirkt hat abseits der ganzen show des
marketings des faschings der skandale
und allerlei politische folklore und ja
wir können nicht alles abhandeln du
kannst uns aber ruhig im
kommentarbereich darauf hinweisen wenn
du der meinung bist wir hätten doch
etwas sehr wichtiges vergessen so an
iris lasst uns mit jedem thema beginnen
welches der 45 präsident der vereinigten
staaten steht selbst aus eine oberste
priorität betrachtet und auf dessen feld
er sich als besonders kompetent ansieht
wirtschaft wirtschaft und nochmal
wirtschaft wahlkampfzeiten sind jene
betreten zeitabschnitte in denen
politiker und das blaue vom himmel
versprechen weniger steuern mehr
freizeit besser straßen wahre demokratie
saubere umwelt bessere bildung und so
weiter und so fort auf diese weise
werden die wahlen zu einer art
orientalischen basar auf den politiker
um unsere stimmen falschen indem sie
sich mit großen versprechungen zu
übertreffen versuchen und wir alle
wissen was aus ihren bombastischen
heilsversprechen wird sobald die wahl
gelaufen ist und diese politiker an die
macht kommen weil dieses ritual haben
wir uns bereits absolut gewöhnt und
sehen ist als teil der ganzen show an
und da donald trump der bekanntermaßen
ein großes showtalent besitzt meisterte
auch diese theatervorstellung im jahr
2016 mit bravour du erinnerst dich nicht
mehr daran was genau er versprach keine
angst wir holen gerne als ein
versprechen aus der mottenkiste des
wahlkampfs 2016 sprachtalent wirklich
von einer zeitenwende
denn die vereinigten staaten würden zum
ersten mal von einem hochgradig
kompetenten geschäftsmann mit
lebenslanger erfahrung in der wirtschaft
professionell und auf höchste
ökonomischen niveau geführt werden und
dies werde zu nicht dagewesen positiven
ergebnissen führen soll ist trump
versprach die vereinigten staaten für
immer zu verändern das
wirtschaftswachstum sollte sich auf vier
bis sechs prozent jährlich vervielfachen
erreichen wollte er dies durch
umfangreiche steuersenkungen und eine
neue handelspolitik außerdem sollte das
enorme außenhandelsdefizit der usa
endlich ausgeglichen werden da ist
seiner meinung nach einem belastung für
die us wirtschaft darstellt und das ist
noch nicht alles er gab auch sein wort
dass es ihnen gelingen werde auch die
staatshaushalt auszugleichen und dass
seine politik erst ermöglichen werde die
gesamte staatsverschuldung des boden
gerissen als 19 millionen dollar in nur
acht jahren abzubauen
am ende dieses gewaltigen
veränderungsprozess wurde das
amerikanische volk einen nie da hat er
diesen wohlstand genießen können da hat
er sich schon ganz schön weit aus dem
fenster gelehnt
also schauen wir uns mal ganz nüchtern
anhand der zahlen an was daraus geworden
ist
[Musik]
und dabei müssen wir feststellen dass
die ersten jahre durchaus nicht schlecht
gelaufen sind zwar nicht phänomenal aber
ist ok in den ersten drei jahren wuchs
die zahl der beschäftigten etwas
langsamer als während der zweiten
amtszeit barack obamas allerdings auf
bereits recht hohen niveau unterdessen
bleibt das durchschnittliche
wirtschaftswachstum höher und auch die
löhne stiegen stärker wenn auch nur
geringfügig um jährlich 1,2 prozent im
vergleich zu einem prozent runter obama
auf der anderen seite sind allerdings
die ausländischen investitionen im jahr
2009 10 auf den niedrigsten stand seit
2006 gesunken wieso das werden wir noch
sehen so und passt gut auf denn all das
kann man nicht richtig einordnen wenn es
isoliert betrachtet diese guten
ergebnisse gegen nämlich mit einer
enormen erhöhung der öffentlichen
ausgaben und einer massiv expansiven
geldpolitik der zentralbanken her sieht
es zum beispiel dieses jahr formale und
das amt sind die öffentlichen ausgaben
im laufe von nur drei haushaltsjahren um
rund 20 prozent gestiegen und die ganzen
krone rettungspakete sind da noch gar
nicht eingerechnet
damit hätten wir im schnitt einen
jährlichen anstieg der staatsausgaben um
mehr als sechs prozent mit anderen
worten sie sind dreimal so stark
gewachsen wie die volkswirtschaft
gleichzeitig hat trump wie versprochen
die steuern gesenkt und es wird ja nicht
natürlich ein klaffendes haushaltsloch
das eines wirtschaftswachstums von mehr
als zwei prozent und vollbeschäftigung
betrug das defizit des bundes im jahr
2019 was 980 milliarden dollar das sind
4,5 prozent des bip und das ist noch
nicht alles für das jahr 2020 wurde noch
bevor jemand etwas von corona die muss
und krise nannte ein defizit von fast 5%
prognostiziert 5 prozent in zeiten einer
prächtig wachsen wirtschaft und
vollbeschäftigung das ist ziemlich
verrückt denn eigentlich gehört es zum
einmaleins des redlichen wirtschaft das
in derart guten zeiten für die
schlechten vorzusorgen
einen puffer für krisenzeiten zu bilden
und nicht am anschlag in seiner
finanziellen möglichkeiten zu
wirtschaften
nur was soll s gestern stand am abgrund
und heute sind wir schon einen schritt
weiter
mitten in der krise
[Musik]
mal sehen ob du erraten wirst wie hoch
aktuelle schätzungen für das bundes
staatsdefizit der usa also für das jahr
2020 sind okay ich will dich nicht auf
die folter spannen aus den fünf prozent
sind sage und schreibe über 17 prozent
geworden aber moment mal hatte dort
nicht versprochen die schulden des
bundes komplett abzubauen also was ist
daraus geworden
der stern deshalb wenden wir mal die
gruoler krise aus betrachten wir also
nur die ersten drei jahre sonst an der
spitze des landes in dieser zeit wuchsen
die staatsschulden um mehr als drei
billionen dollar
das unhcr sind man die real ist halt des
jahres 2020 so haben wir allein zur
jahresmitte bereits und er soll sich mal
fest die sechs billionen dollar marke
überschritten um die eine vorstellung zu
geben das ist mehr als die gesamte
jährliche wirtschaftsleistung japans
oder die summe der jahres babys von
deutschland und frankreich zusammen
genommen so das sind die nackten zahlen
natürlich hat schon das alles ganz
anders verkauft
wir haben dieses land an den höchsten
punkt in seiner geschichte gebracht hat
nie eine wirtschaft wie wir sie haben
wir hatten nie solche zahlen wir werden
sie wieder haben
[Musik]
auf den ersten blick sieht also alles
danach aus dass in puncto
wirtschaftspolitik aline eingefleischten
kritiker recht haben die behaupten er
sei nur ein blender und notorischer
lügner
[Musik]
allerdings darf man nicht die ganze zeit
nur auf zahlen stehen oft wirken sich
nämlich wirtschaftspolitische maßnahmen
ja erst nach langer zeit manchmal erst
in der nächsten oder übernächsten
legislaturperiode aus qualität ist
deswegen oft wichtiger als quantität und
in diesem punkt wenn man etwas genauer
hinsieht hat france wirtschaftspolitik
durchaus einige beantragten erfolge
vorzuweisen er ist betritt die bühne
trommelwirbel der text kz jobs act also
zu deutsch das steuersenkungs und
arbeitsplätze gesetz der regierung trump
gelangt die durchsetzung dieses gesetzes
ende 2017 und es handelt sich um nichts
geringeres als die größte steuerreform
der usa seit 30 jahren wohlgemerkt nicht
die größte steuersenkung sondern eher
eine wirklich grundlegende reform
[Musik]
einkommenssteuer für privatpersonen
wurden nur leicht gesenkt dafür aber
dass steuerwettbewerb zwischen den
einzelnen bundesstaaten gestärkt und vor
allem die körperschaftssteuer
verstärkung durch die einführung einer
art zweittext reduziert bahnbrechend war
jedoch vor allem die änderung des
anwendungsbereiches der
körperschaftsteuer so dass sie nicht
mehr weltweit fällig wird
okay was bedeutet dass anderen worten
ausgedrückt amerikanische unternehmen
müssen nicht mehr in vollem umfang
jene gewinnen besteuern die sie
beispielsweise in europa erzielen
denn dafür sollten sie ja offensichtlich
bereits dort ihre steuern bezahlt haben
zuvor hatten genau deswegen
multinationale unternehmen riesige
mengen an bargeld auf ausländischen
kunden gehortet um sie liegen nicht in
den usa versteuern zu müssen uns durch
diese steuerreform konnten sich diese
gewaltigen rückstellungen auflösen und
das ganze geld in die heimat schließen
lassen es investieren oder aktionäre
ausschütten tatsache ist dass durch
diese maßnahme die stärke
nordamerikanischer unternehmen ihre
wetten dass fähigkeit gut ihr börsenwert
enorm befördert wurde dies war einer der
schlüsselfaktoren für die gute
performance des nordamerikanischen
aktienmarktes in den letzten drei jahren
und an diesem aktienmarkt hängen ihr
könnt nicht auch die museums fonds also
renten vieler millionen us amerikaner
unterm strich kann also sagen dass tron
spyder form eine sehr gute sache ist
welche die us wirtschaft und allen
bürgern auf lange sicht mehr wohlstand
und stabilität bringen dort kommen sie
jetzt zum zweiten großen erfolg
dabei handelt es sich um die tatsache
dass es ihm gelungen ist die maßlose aus
demokratischer bundesvorschriften die
zuvor vollkommen aus dem ruder gelaufen
war zu stoppen paul war präsident rang
nämlich im weissen haus angekommen
und da steht er eine sehr trickreich
executive order welche besagt dass jede
bundesbehörde die eine neue verordnung
ausgeben wollte dass du im gleichen zug
zwei bestehende verordnungen
zurückziehen müsse und falls die neue
verordnung mehrkosten verursachen sollte
müssten diese durch die abschaffung
aller verordnungen gedeckt werden und
obwohl dies am ende nicht zu 100 prozent
funktioniert hat diese executives oder
zumindest dazu geführt dass wir haben's
transmit jungs zeit die schaffung neuer
föderaler vorschriften eingedämmt wurde
man kann dies ganz gut an der anzahl von
seiten des code of federal regulations
beurteilen das ist quasi das
bundesgesetzblatt der usa
indymedia ist ja die bestehenden
bundesförderungen veröffentlicht werden
und schauen mal wie in den letzten
jahren die dicke dieser publikation
relativ stabil geblieben ist weniger
bürokratie erleichtert unternehmen
insbesondere kein unternehmen sich auf
ihren eigentlichen job zu konzentrieren
und produktiver zu sein hat die zahl der
bundesvorschriften zwar nicht verhindern
können aber er konnte den jahr lang hält
iris überbordenden wochen brechen und
das ist sehr wichtig denn die
geschichtswissenschaft hat gezeigt dass
starken bereiche und an zu kultur und
meistens besser wegen untergegangen sind
weil ihr verwaltungsapparat zum
selbstzweck geworden war die
staatsdiener gibt also nicht mehr dem
start in volk sondern ketten die
verhältnisse um der staat und das volk
dient immer mehr und mehr nur dazu eine
immer stärker wuchernde bürokratie zu
alimentieren
[Musik]
wenn solche staatswesen eine solche
gesellschaft sind dann in krisenzeiten
besonders anfällig und auch nicht mehr
gegen äußere feinde verteidigungs weg
sie können in einem solchen zustand zwar
noch eine weile weiter dahinvegetieren
werden dann aber immer durch viele
schlankere und innovativere mächte und
kulturen überhand und erobert und trump
hat im gegensatz zu vielen seiner
kritiker die ihm ja oftmals der bildung
vorwerfen in geschichte wohl gut
aufgepasst und klar erkannt dass an
diesem punkt handeln muss und wie gesagt
hat er das auch gleich am ersten tag
seien habe das ist ebenso klar war auch
dass die usa im außenhandel stark
benachteiligt sind und das riesige
handelsdefizit auf dauer nicht
nachhaltig tragbar sein wird da war
eines seiner wichtigsten politischen
vorhaben diese des ballons durch das
fehlen von zöllen auszugleichen doch
selbst liebt hierfür den martialischen
terminus des kriegs und in weniger als
drei jahren hat trank damit den
welthandel fast auf den kopf gestellt
seine handelskriege richteten sich gegen
rivalen wie hier aber auch gegen
verbündete länder wie kanada mexiko
südkorea und europäische nationen ja das
war schon ganz schön ambitioniert also
was war das ergebnis dieser
auseinandersetzung ist unterm strich
dabei was für die usa herausgekommen nun
eigentlich nicht wirklich nicht nur weil
es die wettbewerbsfähigkeit viele
us-firmen untergraben hat dass sie nun
eine menge zölle auf ihre einkäufe
zahlen müssen sondern auch weil es
seinen wesentlichen zweck nicht erfüllt
hat das wird es der hitze zu reduzieren
sechster oktober 2020 us-handelsdefizit
bringt im august auf höchsten stand seit
14 jahren
mal ganz abgesehen von der tatsache dass
diese zölle westlich vom amerikanischen
bürger bzw unternehmen bezahlt werden
müssen jährlich fließen solides jahr
aber milliarden aus deren taschen in den
staatssäckel
also eigentlich eine steuererhöhung
gewaltigen ausmaßes in der eine
vorstellung davon zu geben unter trump
haben sich die durchschnittlichen us
dollar mehr als verdoppelt was einer der
größten steuererhöhungen seit 1940
entspricht und einen großteil der
steuersenkungen aus dem jahr 2017
zunichte gemacht hat aber es ist noch
lange nicht das ende der fahnenstange
denn auf die erhöhung der zölle auf us
seite haben die anderen länder
ihrerseits mit neuen soll auf ihrer
seite reagiert und dies führte zu einem
einbruch der exporte die zahl in china
verkaufte us-produkte ist heute
niedriger als vor beginn des kriegs den
installer und hilfs beschreibung führt
uns viele amerikanische unternehmen auch
zu mehr bürokratie und höheren kosten
und gleichzeitig führte dies auch so
einem abwürgen der investitionen durch
ausländische firmen in den usa
denn ein handelskrieg stellt für diese
ein unberechenbares investitionsrisiko
da die auslandsinvestitionen in den
vereinigten staaten sind deswegen auf
den niedrigsten stand seit 2006 gesunken
tja ein ziemliches desaster wenn alina
arbeitsplätze welche diese ausländischen
investoren geschaffen hätten
fehlen jetzt zum zeitpunkt der wahlen im
jahr 2020 gab es in den vereinigten
staaten weniger industriearbeitsplätze
hast du derzeit als tramp ins weiße haus
kam und das alles ist noch lange nicht
vorbei
[Musik]
das erste land das ist die größte us
handelsministeriums gerät ist vietnam am
zweiten oktober 2020 wurde eine
untersuchung wegen angeblich unlauteren
wettbewerbs eingeleitet welche zur
verhängung neuer erst zur luft führen
könnte die wir also sehen können hat
trump zwar den einen bürokratischen
moloch gestoppt dafür aber an anderer
stelle einen anderen errichtet und als
er die probleme welche amerikanische
unternehmen durch die handelskriege
entstanden waren dann irgendwie
ausbügeln wollten nichts besseres ein
als subventionen dreiundzwanzigster mai
2009 10 trump kündigt ein neues
hilfspaket in höhe von 16 milliarden
dollar für amerikanische bauern an die
vom handelskrieg betroffen sind nicht
gerade etwas womit sich ein
konservativer politiker rühmen sollte in
wirtschaftlicher hinsicht hat schon
genug zeit also eine sehr gemischte
bilanz hinterlassen
auf der einen seite berühmte die
us-wirtschaft dankeschöns reformen
zumindest bis zum ausbruch der krise so
gut wie nie zuvor und das bei einer sehr
angenehmen inflationsrate andererseits
stellt sich die frage ob dies nicht auf
kosten der zukunft geschehen ist in form
von höherer staatsverschuldung und einer
wirtschaft die auf den globalen märkten
stärker die korona krise hat natürlich
dafür gesorgt dass die
arbeitsmarktzahlen kräftig durcheinander
gewirbelt wurden außerdem darf man davon
ausgehen dass die usa dann ihre sehr
flexibel arbeitsgesetze eine recht große
chance haben sich schnell zu erholen
falls niemand mit neuen lok bei uns und
anderen restriktiven maßnahmen
dazwischen kriegt die jüngsten
arbeitsmarktdaten scheint dies zumindest
zu bestätigen
nächstes thema außenpolitik
[Musik]
reden engel und kalter krieger
oberflächlich betrachtet us außenpolitik
als unberechenbar und erwartet viele
westliche regierungschefs gingen so jump
auf distanz und achten aus ihrer
verachtung gegenüber trump und sei nach
der tüte das britische establishment of
drittel keinen großen hehl
und ja trump hat während seiner amtszeit
viele bewährte regeln der außenpolitik
gebrochen und jede festgetretene pfade
verlassen
trump war zum beispiel der erste
us-präsident seit 40 jahren der keinen
neuen krieg vom zaun gebrochen hat sein
direkter vorgänger barack obama hingegen
hatte die usa in sieben verschiedene zum
teil sehr gewaltsame kriegerische
auseinandersetzungen verwickelt und das
obwohl er bereits im ersten jahr seiner
präsidentschaft den friedensnobelpreis
erhalten hatte
die qualifikation obamas für den
friedens nobelpreis war und ist daher
stark umstritten
trump hingegen war ganz ohne
friedensnobelpreis mit vielerlei
hinsicht wirklich ein präsident des
krieges auch wenn seine zahlreichen
politischen und medialen gegner die es
nie und nimmer zu geben würden
[Musik]
denn anstatt immer wieder nur schöne
reden über frieden zu halten hat er
frieden tatsächlich praktiziert und
durch taten wahrhaft historischer größe
befördert wir sprechen hier von echten
meilenstein der diplomatie die jedoch
leider kaum von der öffentlichkeit
wahrgenommen werden konnten
ob des laufstarken donnergrollen der auf
trump als hassfigur ein passenden rasen
des establishment bedeutendsten war hier
das sogenannte abraham abkommen ein
historisches friedensabkommen das ohne
die kreisregierung nicht ausgehandelt
worden wäre
erst beendete die jahrzehntelange
feindschaft zwischen israel und
wichtigen muslimischen ländern den
vereinigten arabischen emiraten bahrain
und dem sudan
die durchgangs vermittlung erreichte
anerkennung israels durch diese länder
wird nun wahrscheinlich auch dazu führen
dass die übrigen arabischen länder wie
kuwait und saudi arabien in naher
zukunft den gleichen weg einschlagen
werden wir sprechen hier von einer
vollständigen normalisierung der
beziehungen zwischen den arabischen
ländern und israel
das ist etwas was vor einigen jahren
noch undenkbar war und heute dank jump
realität ist und zu einer nachhaltigen
stabilisierung und befriedung des nahen
ostens beitragen wird trump unterstütze
israel außerdem durch die anerkennung
jerusalems als hauptstadt und die
einstellung von umstrittenen zahlungen
an die sogenannte palästinensische
autonomiebehörde aber damit hören toms
außenpolitische erfolge noch lange nicht
auf eine weitere stärke von chinas
außenpolitik war zum beispiel die
rückkehr zur abschreckungspolitik
gegenüber dem mullah regime in iran die
von obama oder eu betrieben appeasement
politik inklusive atom abkommen hat er
es den mullahs wesentlich leichter
gemacht die iranische opposition noch
härter zu unterdrücken
atomwaffenprogramm im geheimen weiter zu
führen und gleichzeitig viele in öl
milliarden scheffeln
john fackelte daher nicht lange herum
kündigte das atom abkommen und ließ
general zudem an den mächtigen chef der
revolutionsgarden
anfangs 2020 durch einen gezielten
luftangriff töten soleimani war eines
der schwergewichte des theokratischen
regimes und maßgeblich für die massaker
an demonstranten und oppositionellen
verantwortlich ein weiterer meilenstein
wäre das präsidentschaft war auch der
siegburger esch der terrororganisation
in syrien und dem irak die sich selbst
über höhen als islamischer staat
bezeichnet mit der hinrichtung ihres
anführers abu bakr al- bagdadi als
hübsches regierung stand auch wie keine
andere zuvor an der seite des von eur
tina bedrohten inselstaats thema wir
haben darüber ein video gedreht das ihr
euch ansehen könnt wenn ihr auf dass sie
oben rechts klickt und last but not
least das friedensabkommen in
afghanistan
mit diesem haben sich die usa quasi aus
dem von george bush begonnen endlos
konflikt zurückgezogen hat so mit diesen
wird einander 2003 jahre ein ende
bereitet zwar steckte dieses abkommen
den einfluss der taliban in afghanistan
aber in diesem festgefahrenen fall war
es extrem ist unklar ob es überhaupt
eine andere reale alternative dazu
gehabt brachte also endlich als erster
den mit aufsicht für das kleinste aller
übel zu entscheiden und jene suppe
auszulassen will die den usa seine
vorgänger bush obama aber auch jimmy
carter in den 70ern eingebracht haben
[Musik]
er hatte durch ein geheimnis ausrüstungs
und ausbildungsprogramm dass die damals
mit ihnen genannten militärstrukturen in
afghanistan aufgebaut diese sollten
damals dies schon wird armin bekämpfen
lassen sich aber schließlich gegen die
muss auch selbst trump ist es auch zu
verdanken dass ein ganz ähnliches
programm seines vorgängers obama name
ist in barßelermoor stoppte
dieses gehalt programm das gestattete
alle möglichen gruppierungen die gegen
den syrischen präsidenten assad kämpfen
wollten mit waffen aus und sorgt auch
für deren top ausbildung viele tausend
dieser kämpfer vagabundieren als zöllner
im nahen osten und sogar den kaukasus
wir haben darüber in einem inneren video
bereits berichtet und auch hier begriff
stammt also im gegensatz zu sagen dass
es sich nicht lohnt die büchse der
pandora zu öffnen
zu verlockend dies auch auf den ersten
blick zu sein scheint trump verstand
aber auch dass es zu einem fliegens
präsidenten wichtig ist mal zähne zu
zeigen damit aggressoren erst gar nicht
auf dumme gedanken kommen neben dem iran
merken dies vor allem auch russland und
hier gegen russland verhängte seine
regierung harte wirtschaftssanktionen
und ging auch gegen unternehmen aus
anderen ländern vor falls diese diese
sanktionen umgehen wollten zum beispiel
im fall des baus der nord stream
pipeline transportiert die
fertigstellung dieser gas pipeline aus
russland nach deutschland um jeden preis
verhindern gegen china zeigte trump eine
noch härtere hand und erklärte dem
asiatischen riesen eine art kalten krieg
das war ein grund bitter nötig denn
peking breitet seine arme schon seit
jahren die sich in alle welt aus das
problem ist nur dass es bis heute
gewinnt der einfluss der chinesischen
regierung und herrschen hingegen ist so
groß wie nie zuvor
afrika zentralasien und sogar die länder
des ehemaligen jugoslawiens sind
beispiele für ganze regionen in denen
china mittlerweile mehr macht hat als
die usa und nicht nur das die rasante
modernisierung der volksbefreiungsarmee
hat die gesamte ostasiatischen region in
ein pulverfass verwandelt sich bringen
konnte den zuvor noch einigermaßen frei
bekommen ein ende bereiten und verlässt
den kommunistischen moloch entgegen
aller versprechungen abkommen sang und
klanglos 1 und über schenken ließ er
dabei hilflos zusehen von trump war
nämlich nichts bedeutendes hierzu zu
vernehmen kein mister gorbatschow im
stile eines riegels nein nicht sehr
traurig denn asien mag uns weit weg
erscheinen aber denkt mal darüber nach
welche bedeutung diese invasion in der
demografisch und wirtschaftlich bereits
wichtigsten regionen der welt für den
ganzen planeten hat nun kommen war zuvor
einer der liberalsten orte der welt und
das alles wurde innerhalb nur weniger
monate von der roten diktatur platt
gemacht hier ging fühlte sich auch
deswegen so stark war schon alles an
munition bereits im handelskrieg
verschossen hatte das ergebnis ist nun
also ein haufen zölle der verlust von
kommst und ein china das
expansionistische ist denn je zuvor
wie hieß noch mal james berühmtes buch
die arbeit auf
man muss davon ausgehen dass es jemandem
peking wohl auch gelesen hat
[Musik]
und in bezug auf so heikle fragen wie
nordkorea die ukraine oder wenn es villa
blieben die bemühungen der regierung
praktisch ergebnislos
tatsächlich wissen wir heute dass wir
uns an den gedanken eines dauerhaft
nuklear ausgerüsteten nordkoreas wohl
gewöhnen müssen
john's fehlschlägen zählt auch sein
fahrrad an den kurden als erdogan freie
hand gab diese aus dem norden syriens zu
vertreiben so wichtig nun also die
bilanz all dieser erfolge und
misserfolge aus das historische abkommen
zwischen israel und den arabischen
ländern sowie die tatsache dass die usa
in weniger kriege verwickelt sind es den
zweifellos gute nachrichten für die usa
wie auch für die ganze welt das ist
trump nicht im geringsten gelungen ist
die von china ausgehende gefahr
einzudämmen lässt für die zukunft jedoch
schlimmes an
vielleicht war seine strategie peking
den offenen handelskrieg zu erklären um
sich zuvor mit dem rest der welt vor
allem europa eigenen zu verbünden ein
großer fehler
was meint ihr dazu wird es gelingen
diesen noch zu korrigieren so kommen wir
nun zur innenpolitik gesundheit justiz
und the wall
auf nationaler ebene gibt es viele dinge
über die gespräche könnten aber drei
themen stechen heraus einwanderung
justiz und gesundheitspolitik lang
wollte einer gesundheitsreform
durchführen aber diese liegt irgendwie
im stadium von plänen und versprechen
stecken was james reform der
gesundheitsreform angeht nun diese blieb
irgendwie im stadium von plänen und
versprechen stecken denn eigentlich
wollte er das zehn jahre alte obamacare
durch etwas vollkommen neues und
großartiges ersetzen aber in all den
jahren seiner präsidentschaft konnte er
sich noch nicht mal innerhalb der
eigenen partei darüber einigen wie das
alles aussehen soll und erinnerst du
dich noch an drums großes versprechen
eine grenze zu mexiko zu bauen und
mexiko dafür auch noch bezahlen zu
lassen die eindämmung der einwanderung
war schließlich das hammer thema seines
2016 der wahlkampf schien regelrecht
besessen zu sein von dieser mauer und
was ist daraus geworden und ist auf vier
jahre später sind kaum fortschritte
vorzuweisen
alle bemühungen zum trotz sind nur 480
kilometer mauer gebaut worden und diese
statistik ist abgestürzt
420 kilometer davon waren einfach nur
renovierungsarbeiten an bereits
bestehenden strukturen unter strich
blieben also 60 km
tom bauer entlang einer größe von mehr
als 3000 kilometern übrig und natürlich
hat mexiko dafür keinen einzigen passus
bezahlt
es wurden nur 480 kilometer mauer gebaut
von denen 420 kilometer reparaturen an
bestehenden strukturen sind mit anderen
worten drums neue mauer hat nach vier
jahren eine länge von gerade mal 60 km
entlang einer grenze von mehr als 3000
kilometer
aber abgesehen von diesen misserfolg in
puncto sowohl politik konnte trump sein
versprechen die massiven
migrationsströme aus mittelamerika zu
stoppen durchaus einlösen denn auch ohne
große und teure mauer konnte er mexiko
mit anderen mitteln dazu bewegen einen
großteil illegalen migranten aus
mittelamerika zurückzuhalten welche
mittel waren die ist nun zum beispiel
über 400 executive orders zur
beschränkung von einwanderung welche die
regierung zu verlassen hat und dabei
wurde nicht gekleckert sondern geklotzt
mit zahlreichen nebenwirkungen zum
beispiel waren davon sogar dieser
betraut
die eigentlich auch leute wie
mathematiker informatiker und ingenieure
ins land holen sollten und seid schon an
die macht kam hat sich der anteil der
abgelehnten anträge vertreibt ob sie aus
vorurteilen trumps einwanderungspolitik
als bedrohung für die us wirtschaft wir
sprechen hier von hochqualifizierten
fachkräften die für die
wettbewerbsfähigkeit amerikanischer
unternehmen von entscheidender bedeutung
sind unterm strich also licht und
schatten in puncto einwanderungspolitik
die hauptanliegen seiner wählerschaft
dürfte hierbei jedoch erfüllt haben
überaus triumphale erfolge konnte trump
jedoch auf dem gebiet der justiz
erringen im jahre 2018 wurde der so
genannte first step unterzeichnet dabei
handelt es sich wie der name schon sagt
um einen ersten schritt zur reform des
maroden us justizsystems dieses längst
überfällige gesetz gestellt die
resozialisierung von verurteilten und
deren wiedereingliederung in ein
normales leben in den vordergrund es ist
schon auch gelungen dank der
republikanische mehrheit im senat drei
konservative richter enden obersten
gerichtshof zu berufen dies wird
vermutlich auf viele jahre eine
konservativ ausgerichtete mehrheit sagt
rekord sicherstellen und damit gelang
das kunststück seinen enormen einfluss
auf die politik der usa
ja die ganze amerikanische gesellschaft
auf viele jahre also lange über die zeit
seiner präsidentschaft hinaus zu
zementieren nur eines wollte von visual
politik hier irgend viele dinge
ausgelassen haben einschließlich des
versucht und angst erhebungsverfahren
seines händlers der korona krise und der
rassenunruhen die beiden letzten themen
sind einfach noch zu heiß und sie
langfristig und abschließend beurteilen
zu können
wir glauben jedoch dass unsere
themenauswahl eine objektive die
politische beurteilung chance ermöglicht
jenseits all der oberflächlichkeiten und
abseits all des pauschalen frank
behälter sowie der lobeshymnen seiner
eingefleischten fans also was weißt du
diesem thema gab es das von shop
angeführte wirtschaftswunder während
seiner regentschaft oder handelt es sich
um ein durch schulden gefüttertes
strohfeuer haben sich all die spannungen
konfrontationen und drohungen in der
außenpolitik gelohnt was konnten wir
daraus lernen und was haben wir
ausgelassen was deiner meinung nach
wichtig gewesen wäre
wie immer sind sie auf eure kommentare
schon hochgradig gespannt lasst uns also
debattieren wir hoffen dass dieses video
gefallen uns vielleicht etwas gebracht
hat was ja gewusst bitte auch einen
daumen hoch unterstütze uns in denen du
es mit einem freund heißt und vergesst
bitte nicht dass wir jede woche neue
videos hochladen
also verpasst keines unserer ab sechs
abonniere unseren kanal klick auf das
symbol und rechtzeitig benachrichtigt zu
werden macht gut und bis zum nächsten
mal
[Musik]